ainsi les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité du jour laurent de baisse
évoque pour commencer la rencontre entre
lionel jospin et tony blair lionel
jospin en visite sur les terres
électorales de tony blair
une entrevue informelle mais riche de
symboles pour ces deux chefs de
gouvernement qui affiche des cotes de
popularité record en europe mais qui
veulent surtout affiché une entente
parfaite
le premier ministre français rend ainsi
la politesse à son homologue britannique
qui était venu à sa rencontre l'été
dernier à cintegabelle c'est d'autre la
réponse du berger à la bergère une
réponse qui plus est en anglais dans le
texte
enfin presque je crois que nous sommes
enfin de trouver chacun notre propre
synthèse et non marchands de concerts je
crois que nous nous rapprochons